In our previous episode, we
looked at the first two steps
necessary when negotiating in English.
We’ve written a whole blog post about this,
so if you want to read on all the language
must-haves when negotiating in English,
click on this link up here.
In this video, we’re going to
move straight on to step number 3.
Making your proposal.
After small talk, and then
reluctantly opening negotiations,
it is time to tell people what you actually want.
We were hoping to interest you in taking
1,000 garden gnomes for your range.
To be honest, we don’t have a
big margin on these products.
However, we would be willing to offer them to you
at a unit price of £5. What are your thoughts?”
Okay, let's just have a quick look
at the language that was used:
To be honest - this is language that
shows that you are being authentic,
vulnerable, transparent, trustworthy.
We would be willing - this language makes
it sound like you’re doing your buyer a favour.
What are your thoughts? Throw them the ball.
You’ve made your proposal, now it’s
time for them to make the next move.
Step and language must-have number 4
Keep calm.
You’ve made your offer, and you might start
to worry that what you’ve offered is too
expensive. British negotiators keep calm. Always.
Because keeping calm influences the language that
you choose to use. So, as a response to your
proposal, you might hear one of these replies:
The coded speech.
I think they’re worth every penny,
but it might be challenging for us
to pay that much from our budget.
The understatement.
Interesting, but that price wasn’t
quite what we were expecting.
Humour, aka the comedian.
That gnome you’ve brought
with you is looking at me and
asking me to buy it for £3
The vague approach - aka the philosopher.
I’ve never really thought about how
much a garden gnome costs to produce.
All four of these responses are saying
the exact same thing. There is no way on earth
that we are paying £5 for one garden gnome!
And that’s it for this video. I’ve gone
through steps 3 and 4 of the language
must-haves when negotiating in
English. If you want to read
all 6, click the link above and it
will take you to the full article!
I’m glad you’ve stayed till the end of this
video. Make sure you subscribe because we have
a lot more business English language
skills that we want to share with you.
If you’re seriously looking to improve
your Business English language skills,
click on the link in the description and it
will take you to the English Online website,
where you can have a look at the courses that
we provide specifically on Business English.
I’ll see you again next time
for our third and final episode.